dust off your total lack of legal
training its pardon season at the white
house that we are pumped he's a
president Trump recently discovered that
he has the power to pardon anyone he
wants it's the only perk he enjoys more
than pointing at two Secret Service
agents and saying you two kiss do the
house of cards thing but whether it's
pardoning or right-wing flamethrower a
spicy sheriff or six months from now
himself Trump is on a mission to wipe
records clean and it just makes sense
the man is very germ conscious Melania
sneezed once last month and he had a
quarantine for 25 days the president's
Pardons have sent a clear message to
honorable law breaking citizens across
the country and now others are begging
to get in on the party former CIA
officer John Kiriakou was investigated
by the DOJ for leaking sensitive
information
he served 23 months behind bars what are
you asking for now I would I would be
forever indebted to the president for a
pardon he's been pardoning people since
he got into office because he knows that
he's doing the right thing I'm humbling
at humbly asking him to correct this
inspiring it takes a lot of integrity to
grovel in front of Brian Kilmeade at
7:00 a.m.
but this is how justice is served in
America if you want clemency you have to
go through the proper channels Fox News
maybe Fox Business the Trump isn't just
offering pardons to like-minded free
thinkers who freethought their way right
into some felonies no he's also helping
the Forgotten men and women of this
country like yesterday when he commuted
the sentence of Alice Marie Johnson a 63
year old woman who had served 21 years
of a life sentence she received as a
first-time nonviolent drug offender and
finally something both sides could agree
Trump got right just like his impeccable
style now of course the lefties say it's
hypocritical for Trump to celebrate
Johnson's release while simultaneously
demanding his Justice Department seek
the same kind of maximum sentences for
drug offenders but Trump commuted
Johnson's sentence because she had the
best legal representation there is last
week Kim kardashian-west met with the
president in the Oval Office to request
a pardon for her there's a celebrity
always have to be involved in order for
the president Department someone oh yeah
everything is better with celebrities
the justice system Rap Battles Japanese
coffee commercials everything I knew
better to be your advocate than Kim
Kardashian if she can make eating salad
into a hit show for 14 seasons you can
do anything
yes that's a packed look it up
[Applause]
Trump knows what he's doing his pardons
are based on the advice of veteran legal
experts with excellent IMDB ratings for
example Trump pardon 19:08 heavyweight
champion Jack Johnson after thorough
consultation with Sylvester Stallone two
great Americans who are both very tough
on Russia when the cameras are rolling
the point is this is how justice is done
in America and here at the opposition we
found a way to connect the ugly face of
injustice with the symmetrical face of
celebrity are you a non-violent offender
currently serving a life sentence is it
hard to find anyone to help your case
like a lawyer or a senator or an entire
justice system then you need a celebrity
introducing beg your pardon beg your
pardon uses the shop positions high-tech
algorithm to match currently
incarcerated low-level offenders with
famous people who might bump into Donald
Trump when I was 15 years old I stole a
pair of sneakers 40 years later I was
still in Rikers then I connected with
Olympians Shaun White he snow brought in
all the rain of mar-a-lago and let trump
take pictures with his gold medal they
let me out six hours later thanks you
beautiful ginger every week beg your
pardon helps the unjustly incarcerated
with aid from celebrities like Adam
Levine Heidi Montag and Spencer Pratt
Chewbacca mom thank you for my freedom
Luis FONSI featuring daddy yankee
because Donald Trump has the power to
change the entire justice system but
isn't this war fun
the fight continues you your deep state
operative is sent by George Soros to
take away my Second Amendment rights and
force-feed me soy burgers No well then
prove it click and subscribe and join
the opposition now